this is an interesting
thing like we're all what is that there
are several billion of us
and we're kind of roaming this world and
then you kind of stick together
you find find somebody that just like
gets you
and it's interesting to think about
there's probably
thousands if not millions of people that
would would
be sticky to you depending on the
curvature of your space
but what what is the
could you speak to the stickiness like
to the just the falling in love like
seeing that somebody really gets you
maybe
by way of um telling
do you think do you remember there was a
moment when you just
realized damn it i think i'm like i
think that's
this is the guy i think i'm in love we
were having these conversations
actually from the really from the second
weekend we were together so he flew back
the next weekend to state college
because my birthday was my 30th birthday
my friends were throwing me a party
and we went hiking and we hiked up some
mountain and we were sitting on a cliff
over this you know overlook and talking
to each other and i was thinking and i
actually said to him like i
i haven't really known you very long but
i feel like i'm falling in love with you
which can't possibly be happening i must
be projected
but it certainly feels that way right
like i don't believe in love at first
sight so this can't really be happening
but it sort of feels like it is and he
was like i know what you mean
and so for the first three months or
four months we would say things to each
other like
i feel like i'm in love with you but
you know but that can't but things don't
really work like that
so but you know so and then it became a
joke like
i feel like i'm in love with you and
then eventually you know
i think um but i think that was one
moment where we were
we were talking about i don't know just
you know not just all the great
aspirations you have or all the things
but also things you don't like about
yourself things that you're worried
about
things that you're scared of and then i
think the
that was sort of solidified the
relationship and then there was one
weekend where we went to maine in the
winter
which i love i mean i really love the
beach always
but in the winter particularly because
it's just beautiful and
calm and whatever yeah and i also i i do
find beauty in starkness
sometimes like so there's this grand
majestic
scene of you know this very powerful
ocean and it's all these like beautiful
blue
grays and it's just it's just stunning
and so we were sitting on this huge rock
in maine
and where we had gone for the weekend it
was freezing cold
and i honestly can't remember what he
said
or what i said or what but i
i definitely remember having this
feeling
of um i absolutely want to stay with
this person like i
and i don't know what my life will be
like if i'm not with this person like i
need to be with this person
can we from a scientific and a human
perspective
uh dig into your belief that first
love at first sight is not is not
possible you don't believe in it
well because there is there you don't
think there's like a magic where you
see somebody in the in the jack kerouac
way and you're like
wow that's something that's that's a
special little
oh i definitely oh i definitely think
you can connect with someone
instant in an instance and i definitely
think you can say oh there's something
there and i'm really clicking with that
person
romantically but also just with friends
it's possible to do that you recognize a
mind that's
like yours or that's compatible with
yours
there are ways that you feel like you're
being understood or that you understand
something about this person or maybe you
see something in this person that you
find
really compelling or intriguing
but i think you know your brain is
predictive organ
right you're using your past you're
projecting
you're using your past to make
predictions
and i mean not deliberately that's
how your brain is wired that's what it
does and so it's filling in
all of the gaps that you
you know there are lots of gaps of
information that you don't
you know information you don't have and
so your brain is filling those in
and um
but isn't that what love is no i don't
think so
actually i mean to some extent sure you
you always
you know there's research to show that
people who are in love
always see the best in each other and
they
you know when there's a when there's a
negative interpretation or positive
interpretation you know they choose the
positive ones there's a little bit of
positive illusion there
you know going on that's what the
research shows but i think
um i think that
when you find somebody who
not just appreciates
your faults but loves you for
them actually you know like maybe even
doesn't see them as a fault
that's you so you have to be honest
enough
about what your what your faults are
so it's easy to love someone for all the
things that they
um
for all the wonderful characteristics
they have it's
harder i think to love someone despite
their faults or maybe even the faults
that they see aren't really faults at
all to you they're actually
something really special but isn't isn't
that can't you explain that by saying
the brain kind of
like you're projecting it's you're
you have a conception of a human being
or just a spirit that really connects
with you and you're projecting that
onto that person and yes
within that framework all their faults
then become beautiful like little
maybe but you you just have to pay
attention to the prediction error
no but maybe that's what love like maybe
you ignore you start ignoring the
prediction error that's
maybe love is just your ability uh
like to ignore the prediction error well
i think that there's some research that
might say
that but that's not my experience i
guess
um but there is some research that says
i mean there's some research that says
you have to have an
optimal margin of illusion which means
that you
um that you put a positive spin on
on smaller things but you don't ignore
the bigger things right
and i think without being judgmental at
all
when someone says to me you know um
you're not who i thought you were i mean
nobody says i said that to me in a
really long time but certainly when i
was younger
that was you know you're not who i
thought you were my reaction to that was
well whose fault is that you know
yeah um i'm a pretty i'm a pretty
upfront person um
i mean i will though say that in my
experience
people people don't lie to you
about who they are they lie to
themselves in your presence
yeah um and so you know
you don't want to get tied tied up in
that
tangled up in that and i think from the
get-go
dan and i were just for whatever reason
maybe it's because we both have been
divorced already and
you know um
you know he told me who we thought he
was
and he he was pretty accurate as far as
pretty much actually i mean i there's
very
i can't say that i've ever come across a
characteristic in him that
really surprised me in a bad way
it's hard to know yourself it it is hard
to know to communicate that
for sure i mean i'll say you know
i had the advantage of training as a
therapist which meant for five years i
was under a microscope
yeah um you know when i was training as
a therapist
it was hour for hour supervision which
meant if you were in a room with a
client for an hour
you had an hour with a with a supervisor
so that supervisor was behind the mirror
for your session and then you went and
had an hour of discussion about what you
said
what you didn't say learning to use your
own
react your own feelings and thoughts as
a tool
to probe the mind of the client and so
on and so
you can't help but learn a lot of you
can't learn help but learn a lot about
yourself in that process
you